with the graveyard book each chapter is
also a story in itself so I thought why
don't I go on the road and read a whole
chapter and then do a long Q&A get
people to write questions down on cards
I'll do 30 questions a night instead of
4 questions and that's what I've been
doing and then the next bit of the idea
was well if I'm gonna do that
why don't we stream it why don't we put
them up on the web so right now we have
the rather peculiar thing of at the same
time as we're selling the book we're
giving it away a chapter at a time what
I love about that is that it creates
something special everybody around the
world can follow along with us everybody
can they can link to they can embed the
video on their website if they want they
can do what they like with it I love
that the idea of the graveyard book came
to me one that I was a very young man
when my son was almost 2 years old lived
in a really tall house and he had a
tricycle and he couldn't ride the
tricycle around the house because he
would have tumbled down stairs and died
so we didn't have a garden so I would
take him across the lane to the little
graveyard over the road and he would
peddle his tricycle up and down the
paths and between the graves and one day
I looked at him and I thought you know
he looked so uh
and then I thought I should write a book
that would be kind of like kiplings the
jungle book.ghost Ori about a kid and
wanders into a graveyard and is brought
up by dead people and has talked all the
things that dead people know and that's
really the graveyard book children tend
to read the graveyard book as an
exciting sort of book with a hero that
they would love to be parents I think
tend to read it essentially as a giant
metaphor for childhood and the joy and
the tragedy a parenthood I don't realize
that I've made that work until people
started phoning me up and saying they
cried I didn't know that I was writing a
book about growing up when I started
writing it I just knew that my hero
would have to grow up and that I would
do a story every two years but trying to
find who he was at two year intervals
was fascinating okay
what are you when you're four that you
aren't when you're eight what are you
when you're six that you want when
you're 12 when I look back at my
childhood the biggest difference between
you know that the childhood of kids
today and the one that I had is mostly
for the last ten years I've known were
my children what I got to just vanish a
lot anytime between the end of school
and being home for dinner was mine and I
would wonder these trespassing on vast
closed down country estates which have
now all been turned into housing estates
but these sort of
giant manor houses which were all locked
up if I couldn't sit and read I wanted
to just wander and explore and I loved
getting lost one of my favorite books
when I was little was tales of the
Norseman tales of the the Norse gods
tales of ancient Egypt those by by
writers like roger lancelyn green and
their retellings of mythology tales of
greece and rome and I'd read them and I
love them with the graveyard book that I
really didn't want to go into an
existing mythology I thought it was much
more fun to try and create mythologies
and to try and create a mythology of
graveyards which felt right you know the
ghouls aren't from any mythology there's
probably a tiny - of HP Lovecraft in
them but apart from that they're just
they are their own thing whether or not
kids will find this scary I don't know I
hope not I would much rather that the
graveyard book acted as a kind of
inoculation I would love to make kids
less scared of the world they're in I
would love to make them less scared of
things like graveyards and the dead
because one of the things of the book is
that the dead can't hurt you they're
dead living things can hurt you living
people can hurt you the dead cart
[Music]
you